[Music]
the world works in certain ways until a
new great idea comes along and changes
everything
[Music]
what if you could test your blood in
your own home
and what if it wasn't a whole vial but
just a drop
[Music]
i'm going to drop out of stanford this
machine is going to change the world
these kids don't overthink they don't
get bogged down about the way things
have always been done
they want to change things now
together we're making healthcare
accessible to everyone in this country
i don't understand how you're doing this
extremely complex chemical engineering
with a high school degree this
technology is 10 years away your idea is
impossible so you just keep trying do or
do not there is no try
that's yoda
okay
if you want this you have to dedicate
yourself what are you willing to do to
get it i can't give them one reason to
doubt me it's not even close to working
yet
what are we gonna show with a demo we're
gonna tell them that we don't have a
working prototype
right our series being closed at 165
million get the money
i know what you did at the demo the demo
was an inspiring step forward
don't tell anyone else i'm going to
protect you this is an inspiring and
inspiring step
forward this isn't just my job this is
who i am
anybody who doubts my company
doubts me
you're ceo of a billion dollar company
what are you afraid of
her whole image is fake we have to stop
her
we haven't seen a single contract she is
lying to you
you're in over your head going to lose
everything
no i'm i'm fine everything's fine
you don't understand the business and
you don't understand the silence
your company was endangering lives
this is your dream your story
people will trust the technology
because they will trust you
[Music]
you